bon alors que ouais justement amadeus et
l émission de l'annuel d'accord et là il
fait dire la vérité on va me laisser
passer en plateau et au rachat se passer
est d'accord non mais un moment donné
j'avais abandonné parce qu'il sait qu'il
revient voilà vont-elles se coller à
castanet à mons ouest il à webo le
terrible un sort tout le monde à qu'est
ce qui vous arrive sur vous êtes filmés
alors gérard michel les côtes d'armor
interquartiers de pétanque entraver le
midem u 17 17
[Musique]
je vous donne leur bon de le stopper
voir deuxième émission 3 millions et
puis là il est descendu mais oui il
découpe des fruits avec un alors marlène
sépare pas j'aime pas trop vite rangé
chaude jeunesse sachant qu'une mesure
j'ai peur que ça passe je suis pas le
papa jamie dimon
voilà soudain surgi face au monde le
vrai héros de tous les temps des
récentes voilà plutôt de moder bas je te
survivrai d'amour impossible j'étais
déçu je te suivrai toujours baigné dans
les jours les prisons ce furent vie
volée